si vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a de l'espoir pour le
monde, cela
pourrait prendre la peine de continuer
Je vois le monde
[Musique]
vous ne savez pas que
vous continuez pour la famille
Je ne suis pas de la famille pas de
cargaison
[Musique]
pourquoi es-tu si important
Quelque part dans l'Ouest, ils travaillent sur un
remède, je pense que ce qui les a vraiment impressionnés,
c'est le fait que je ne me suis pas transformé en
monstre que vous voyez autant que des contractions,
ça va
[Musique]
si je t'emmène avec moi tu fais quoi  Je
dis quand je le dis,
tu as des conseils sur le meilleur chemin vers l'ouest
ouais va vers l'est
si tu es venu jusqu'ici
alors tu sais ce qu'il y a là-bas
tu ne vas pas nous faire
peur lui a fait peur
[Musique]
plus grand but que n'importe lequel d'entre nous  Je
n'aurais jamais pu imaginer
faire attention en qui vous mettez votre foi,
vous n'êtes peut-être pas son père, elle était Fils,
vous me faites confiance
[Musique]